writer director Christopher macquarrie
has been slowly reintroducing elements
from past mission impossible
installments into his overarching
narrative for years it's clear that
mission impossible is attempting to
build a cohesive story that connects to
everything that's come before one key
returning element is former IMF director
Eugene kittridge played by Henry zurny
who hasn't appeared since the first film
kittridge was eventually succeeded by
Alec Baldwin's CIA director Alan Hundley
but it's never explained on screen what
happened to kittridge in the meantime
xerne revealed that he came up with his
own backstory for kittridge following
the events of the first movie telling
slash film I decided that he'd been to
all the agencies on some level or
another had a good idea now of how the
game is played and what his place is in
this mechanism of National Intelligence
Ethan's School in kittridge on who the
mole really was and catching the mole
was the springboard to 25 years of
kittridge going through different
agencies so he wouldn't be schooled
again